an oval office revelation from President
Trump after nearly a year of
negotiations the president said he's
finished writing out answers to
questions from the special counsel that
suggests a big breakthrough in Robert
Muller's investigation the president
told reporters yesterday that Muller's
investigation now in its 18th month
should not have been allowed to begin
but he added it was very easy for him to
answer the written questions
Errol Barnett is at the White House good
morning Errol good morning you're right
during months of negotiations the
president's legal team works to narrow
the focus of questions from the special
counsels team and just this past week
work with the President on those written
answers what we know is that potential
collusion with Russia is an area
addressed but obstruction of justice is
not I was asked a series of questions
I've answered them very easily
president Trump said responding to
questions from special counsel robert
muller regarding russian interference in
the 2016 election was simple but it
didn't take very long to do them and
they were my answers I don't need
lawyers to do that but added he hasn't
submitted his written answers yet
because he can't do you need lawyers for
submitted lawyers to go over some of the
answers the 18-month probe into Russian
meddling already yielded indictments of
32 individuals six of either pleaded or
been found guilty including the
president's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and campaign
chairman Paul Manafort they should have
never been and in a so-called
investigation which in theory it's not
an investigation of me but it's as far
as I'm concerned I like to take
everything personally also facing the
president an ongoing legal battle with
CNN reporter Jim Acosta
Acosta's White House press pass was
revoked
following this testy exchange with the
president which resulted in a lawsuit
from CNN that's enough on Friday a trump
appointed federal judge in Washington
said the government was unable to say
who made the initial decision to revoke
mr. Acosta's hard pass and ordered the
White House at
temporarily reinstated Kostas credential
go back to work shortly after the
decision Acosta was back on White House
grounds I'm really grateful to all of my
colleagues in the press who stood by us
the White House said it is going to
develop rules and processes to ensure
fair and orderly press conferences in
the future if they don't listen to the
rules and regulations we'll end up back
in court and we'll win
now the judge's order was just a
temporary restraining order which
typically lasts about two weeks and
another hearing is set for Monday for
part two of this legal battle right now
president Trump is enroute to California
where he is scheduled to make multiple
stops in areas devastated by the
historic fires there Anthony
they're all Barnett at the White House
thanks Errol